you
see I like this little countdown
I guess we'll try it
Sicilian land
you
so how are you guys all doing tonight
it's been a it's been a while since I
streamed in an evening
been doing some Oh
well as it turns out some European
friendly streams
but really just came down to that was a
time I was able to do it
um
alright let's just stop any g4 idea
thanks general advance
I guess we'll put the bishop here let's
see where he's gone Queen side Kings
side gonna keep me guessing for one more
move now
so he's jumping right in zurk Master
so he's gonna go here
the dragon vinegar Bob I have a tough
time playing both sides of it
yeah that's definitely not a strong suit
of mine
okay that move I feel like I could do a
good job on the dark squares now I'm
going to start with this check and they
have to block with the bishop or gone
castled
so as soon as this move is played this
square lit up in my mind it's a hole so
I'm cool it's just taking and I could
even think about this move do I want to
do that right now
I think I do so this is a very nice
long-term feature structurally
one pond restricting to we could start
to look into good versus bad Bishop
stuff also Queen g5 move she could now
let's say rely upon g5 she can't be
scared away with h4
and I think I may just want to jump in
there straight away if I don't do this
maybe this move I think this is
something
white would like to do if ever a capture
this this night could play
let's see one thing that kind of bothers
me is
night here but you know what
if if something like this maybe I'm okay
if they take out my beep on I'll Castle
kingside and maybe I could use this open
file
I'm not concerned about this because I'm
gonna rule that out with my next move
here so they could go pawn hunting
although I don't have to get I could go
here
I think I just want to exchange
yeah you know I won't exchange cuz
ha what's my reasoning
want to keep my queen defending here
because I want to be able to castle so
my rook isn't going to want to be
babysitting this pawn
and my idea here was to play this move
next
now that the bishop can't make use of
that weekend square
and do I really want to do all of this
before I Castle I think I do the I'm not
doing this just to scare the night away
but I don't want to see him even arrive
here now
okay now if I do this he could go here
because he's pinned so this is a good
time to get my butt to safety
so opposite sides castling
this is serious could one day if I have
a pond here get my queen here and game
over so we're definitely starting with
this
there was a fight going on over c5
ah what more
they're gearing up for this advance
I'm okay if they do this I'm an exchange
I'll play off five and even if the
Knights aren't on board this is
something pretty serious I believe I'm
on the rook Carly yes it doesn't have
too many options Queen is pretty active
Thank You realms thirty-two appreciate
the support okay that move let's uh
let's put a dent
in their kings
structure
not doing anything about that Wow
you
okay
I'm gonna take him
let's stay here defend this keep
pressure on stuff a lot of stuff
anything now
holy cow you're just ignoring this stuff
I have him defended so now this pressure
here
gotta keep my eyes peeled my opponent
does not care
look active
this doubling up I can meet with g6
or even just take the night
you
I'm gonna go here I'm giving them this I
I just chickened out there
let's keep them in a pin
I think I just want to take the night
see if I could induce some weaknesses
first
I'm I really need to pay
tension
- the clock situation
I want to get one rook off
looking to converge here make a night
move
you
okay let's just go here let them
recapture on this square
okay one rook is
I feel like I could get really active
with my queen
I'll take him now we're gonna go on the
a file this is going hitting really fast
king is naked mate threat no time for
this
I also just here to pick up the rook is
good too
just uh delaying stuff and that's my
okay that wasn't a clean ending there
I think my opponent had his chances
taking on b2 he should have captured on
d6
you